well I'm on the moon funny how that
happens well while I'm here I might as
well do some moonwalking but I don't
really know how to do moonwalking so I'm
gonna ask coolly Jackson the
choreographer the top MJ the move back
in the day hi my name is Cooley Jackson
and I'm one of the guys who taught
Michael Jackson the moonwalk the actual
name of the step is called the backslide
Michael chose to call it the moonwalk I
was a Mighty Morphin Power Ranger in a
show called Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
live traveling show I played the white
ranger for a couple of years with that
so that was pretty cool so here are the
steps you got to start with your left
foot pivoted down so you start with your
heel off the ground and your toe planted
firmly start with your right foot
slightly in front but flat against the
ground now the first thing you're gonna
do is just keep your right knee locked
and you're gonna drag your right leg
straight back behind the other one
you're gonna keep it flat on the floor
the entire time and at the same time
you're gonna move your left hand back
you're moving backwards but you're
simulating forward walking with your
body which is why you move your arm so
once you've moved your right foot back
flat you want to pivot weight from your
left side over to your right side by
spending your knees now this is what's
actually called popping and locking so
you pop and lock and then you do the
exact same move on the other side so you
slide your left foot back flat moving
your right arm back and then you do the
same thing you pop and lock
here we go drag drag drag drag again
drag drag drag drag so once you've
broken down each step and figured it out
you need to put it all together but it's
a lot harder than it looks as you try to
speed up you'll notice you'll start kind
of getting a little bit out of shape and
out of sorts but just keep practicing it
do it step by step and you'll be you
know you'll be moonwalking as good as me
in no time
you